and now I'm in position to talk about
what is the maximum force
if I push F harder as fat push F and the
Box go together the accelerations are
the same
I push F harder the accelerations are
the same
I pushed F harder and I push up so hard
that the static friction is no longer
reaches its maximum value and if I push
that harder than that I will not have
the static friction can't get bigger and
the blocks one and two will start to
slip relative to each other
so my no slipping condition is that I
want two things a one equals a 2 we'll
call that a and the maximum force
condition is that F static is equal to
maximum value now what is the normal
force between that we refer to in our
friction law there's two normal forces
the ground and the normal force between
the surfaces but the static friction
that we're talking about is between the
surfaces so that's why we use in here
and not end ground and now I can solve
for this F max by the way we also have
the condition that FK is nu K what
normal force are we talking about and
which we've called n ground one and now
I look at my equations and my goal is to
solve for F I know ng 1 from this
equation it's just equal to m1 G Plus n
I know n from that equation so mg 1 is
just the sum of the masses times G so I
know this I have F
which is M to a and I can now apply my
result so what we'll do is we'll solve
for the A's a 1 equals a 2 in terms of F
max so over here we have that a is F
over m 2 that's from this equation and
now I'll substitute a 1 is equal to that
I'll substitute that there and I get
that F max is going to be equal to FK
plus F static max that's that 1 plus m1
times a 1 which is F static Max divided
by m2 and so I get that F max equals now
I'm going to substitute in all of these
values it's going to look a little
complicated and so I'd like to have a
little space here for that to get
everything in here
and we'll see that it's equal to MU K
and 1 plus m2g FK u k plus M 1 to M G
Plus F static max times 1 plus M 1 over
m 2 but f static max is mu N and n is m2
G so I get M 2 G times 1 plus M 1 over M
2 and there is if I push any harder than
that
bak 2 will slip with respect to block 1
again all of our terms
have the dimensions of acceleration this
is dimensionless one dimensions of
acceleration and we did miss one little
thing we missed the coefficient of
static friction and there we have it
tricky problem